what you said now why cuz I'm not Gina
huh talking about a titties and [ __ ]
whatever
I've had these titties for three years
y'all never complimented them once where
my lady fans at holla all three of y'all
[Music]
going on YouTube both of us I heard the
story
this one is damn interesting apparently
a woman from Quebec fixed a quintuplet
pregnancy till the night month now I
know there are some of you uneducated
[ __ ] out there and then don't
know what Quebec is that's in Canada
sounds like it's from Asia though
doesn't it Shalom and miss the phone
Quebec that's right she faked a five
baby pregnancy to the last second until
her boyfriend found out now already this
article a couple things came to mind now
for the guy as the future father of
these non-existent babies I feel
absolutely horrible for you but on the
other hand what the [ __ ] do you think
how did you not know that your
girlfriend was not pregnant until the
ninth month of her pregnancy you know
why because you ain't yet oh you gonna
get up [ __ ] when I got a
pregnancy test like that because you
know because people deny that [ __ ] even
if they know it's their baby I'm
pregnant [ __ ] how you know that the
pregnancy test well you know that
paternity test baby what's that over
there
not because through the whole nine yards
you never saw her but maybe once you
never even trying to feel the baby kick
listen I'm not stupid
acqua watching a lot of white American
television when a baby comes through the
stomach you're supposed to put your hand
on and be like Oh God
I felt it you guys never see a thug feel
his baby kick for the first time she's
funny as hell they try to act all hard
while it's tears coming out the side of
the cheek and [ __ ]
baby come for the baby kick [ __ ] I'll
give a [ __ ] about no baby let me see
that [ __ ] you prep my man i'ma put it to
you like this think about that's ten
baby feet inside of my best octopus plus
two and not one of them kick your
stomach one [ __ ] if something doesn't
move but not months they did now another
part of the article stated that this
pregnancy could have been a phantom
pregnancy yes maybe a single big but
five not only are you good at deceiving
your boyfriend
lie to your body and even that
[ __ ] believed you let me ask you
something how you get your kidneys to
lactate on command I get that [ __ ] crazy
weather listen here boyfriend that got
bulls understand this that you dodged
the bullet mmm crazy bullet at that but
but according to the article she has
been something like this before and she
is now seeking psychiatric help so in
all honesty I do hope that she gets the
help that she needs and she gets better
but I'm telling you right now that if
you lived in America you would have
solved this problem easily just go to
Mario Jerry Springer they wanna fix that
[ __ ] up you are not the father oh my god
Oh cats for the Friendly Ghost [ __ ]
they don't exist Oh what is going on yes
gum gum in my mouth let's take this out
put it on the table yes that concludes
this one for this week and yes that blog
was suggested by I hurt you so yeah I
know some of these articles are old it's
because well we kind of just have to go
along with it because you guys suggested
it and I thought it [ __ ] hilarious now
once again if you guys want to be a part
of these vlogs you don't have to suggest
articles only you could just you know
suggest topics that you guys want me to
talk about in general and I want you
guys to get involved as well once again
if you guys are wondering about the gear
that I wear these shirts that just go
for broke apparel stuff right here girl
from Brooklyn peril calm right there go
ahead copy gear and yes you'll be
looking fresh as [ __ ]
remember funny fat fit once again is on
Wednesdays so stay tuned for that and
yes even if you're not trying to get fit
hey there entertaining his [ __ ] to
watch it anyways I will see you guys
whens day Wednesday Wednesday Wednesday
hahaha apparently Oh mmm my voice
apparently hair on the balls fix a
quintuplet prank becomes dominant
apparently a woman from cookware high
hmm apparently a woman from Quebec face
it